herzlich willkommen was unterscheidet
uns menschen von einem thermometer wenn
die sonne uns ins gesicht scheint
registrieren wir nicht nur dass es warm
ist sondern wir fühlen diese wärme auch
und erleben die frierend heiße luft doch
warum erleben wie überhaupt etwas und
erleben sie das selbe wie ich die frage
nach dem bewusstsein beschäftigt die
philosophie seit jahrhunderten
ich bin sehr froh sie heute mit einem
der führenden experten zu diskutieren
nämlich mit david james
er ist professor für philosophie und
neurowissenschaften an der new york
university und dann der australian
national university in canberra herzlich
willkommen
danke das freut mich sehr hier zu sein
naja schauen was sie sind einer der
führenden experten wenn es um diese
frage des bewusstseins geht kann man
ganz kurz sagen worum geht's eigentlich
und coaches bewusstsein ist das
subjektive erleben unseres geistes und
der welt wenn ich sie anschaue strömt
ein informationsfluss durch mein gehirn
signale stimulieren die retina in meinen
augen und werden als elektrische
aktivität an mein gehirn geleitet
das dann vielleicht eine antwort
produziert von außen mag ich dabei
aussehen wie ein großer roboter wie eine
maschine
es gibt aber auch eine innere
perspektive in der art sie zu erleben
ich habe ein bild von der welt ich höre
geräusche ich habe ein körpergefühl
mir ist heiß oder kalt ich mache
gedanken erfahrungen
das sind alles bestandteile des films in
meinem kopf oder eben von bewusstsein
der innere vielen das hat zum beispiel
ein thermometer nicht das thermometer
denkt nicht ich bin ein thermometer die
meisten leute werden sich wohl einig
dass ein thermometer kein subjektives
erleben kennt ein thermometer scheint
ein rein objektives gerät zu sein
es reagiert auf wärme in dem das
quecksilber sich ausdehnt
auch ich kann dir ein thermometer
reagieren dreht man die heizung auf
beginne ich vielleicht zu schwitzen und
sage es wird heiß das ist rein objektiv
aber wie es sich für mich an fühlt ist
subjektiv wahrscheinlich spürt das
thermometer im gegensatz zu mir die
hitze nicht wenn es 40 grad anzeigt über
all diese fragen werden die sprechen
doch was ihre lösung ist für dieses
problem des bewusstseins für die sie
gerne zuerst noch ein bisschen besser
kennen lernen sie sind ja in australien
aufgewachsen und sie haben mathematik
studiert in oxford wenn man bücher über
sie liest oder interviews mit ihnen dann
kriegt man mit sie haben sehr früh sich
schon für mathe interessiert sie haben
ganz viele mathematische rätsel gelöst
als kleiner junge waren später auch für
australien an der mathematik-olympiade
also sie waren ein richtig guter
mathematiker muss ich sie mir als
kleiner junge so als kleiner nerd
vorstellen dass ein kopf
ich würde mich selbst wohl als gut
beschreiben als zahlen fried ich war
besessen von mathematik
naturwissenschaft und computern alles
naturwissenschaftliche habe ich geradezu
verschlungen
damit die mathematik als das
grundlegendste überhaupt erschien wollte
ich mathematiker werden weil ich die
grundlagen der welt verstehen wollte
wir sehen die chemie als elementare als
die biologie noch elementarer ist die
physik aber am elementarsten ist die
mathematik denkt man aber etwas weiter
sieht man dass es noch etwas
fundamentales gibt nämlich philosophie
ich wurde in den strudel philosophischer
fragen hineingezogen
warum sind die dinge so wie sie sind
welche sind die fragen auf welche die
wissenschaft noch keine antwort gefunden
hat so fiel mir auf dass wir mit unserem
wissenschaftlichen denkens kein
verständnis
vom bewusstsein den menschlichen geist
grund wie es zu verorten ist
und das hat ja eigentlich schon sehr
früh angefangen sie haben ja bevor sie
dann eben mathematik studiert haben mit
einem stipendium in oxford eine reise
gemacht vier monate sind sie auch durch
europa gereist und auf dieser reise
haben sie auch buddhistische schriften
zu lesen begonnen sie haben sich mit
zehn tourismus befasst das dauerte
schien gelesen aber auch die
theoretischen schriften von umberto eco
hermann hesse hat sie interessiert wie
viele junge menschen
was ist ihnen geblieben aus dieser zeit
und ging es da auch schon um das problem
des bewusstseins speziell interessiert
das thema des bewusstseins war schon
präsent als ich noch mathematik
studierte ich besuchte damals einen kurs
in philosophie es lief allerdings nicht
so gut es war meine schlechteste prüfung
ich kriegte nur ein b sonst ein
ich war also nicht so toll aber das
regte mich zum nachdenken an über fragen
des geistes und die beziehung zur
mathematik
ich sah das als liebhaberei wie viel zu
interessant und spaßig sei als dass man
dafür bezahlt würde die liebhaberei
wurde dann mehr und mehr zur
besessenheit trampte quer durch europa
und füllte am straßenrand mein notizbuch
mit verrückten ideen über das
bewusstsein
schließlich wurde mir klar dass ich es
ernsthafte angehen musste wollte ich
mich als mathematik studentin
philosophie programm einschreiben um
über philosophie und fragen des geistes
nachzudenken
man sagte mir ich werde verrückt dass
seriöse fach mathematik die mich gut war
zu verlassen für die unsichere
philosophie von der ich keine ahnung
hatte dieses studium in angriff zu
nehmen war für mich ein sprung ins
ungewisse waren sie darin auch ziemlich
gut sie gehören mit sicherheit zu den
bekanntesten philosophen
zweiter zurzeit ich würde gerne mit
ihnen eine art reise unternehmen in
diese frage des bewusstseins hinein und
würde vorschlagen dass wir uns mal
vorsichtig herantasten die können ja
vielleicht einfach mal damit beginnen
uns zu überlegen was gibt es eigentlich
in der welt und die meisten leute würden
ja sagen es gibt auf der welt zum
beispiel bücher
es gibt wasserfälle es gibt pflanzen es
gibt iphones und thermometer und diesen
tisch und es gibt zahnschmerzen
liebeskummer nervosität die pläne die
wir uns machen
es gibt also dinge die aus material
bestehen und es gibt nicht materielles
das ist wahrscheinlich so ungefähr die
position des dualismus das ist eine sehr
intuitive betrachtungsweise der realität
es geht materielle dinge die man
berühren spüren und herumschieben kann
und es gibt mentale dinge erfahrungen im
kopf gedanken gefühle und empfindungen
aus wissenschaftlicher warte ist man
heute geneigt zu sagen dass alles
physikalisch begründbar ist die physik
sieht sich als grundlegende wissenschaft
der realität die physiker selbst streben
eine theorie von allem an
sie bezeichnen es als die theorie des
universums ähnlich ist es in vielen
anderen wissensbereichen die biologie
erklärt viele aspekte des lebens der
reproduktion und der genetik auf
molekularer grundlage
das heißt mit der chemie die chemie
wiederum kann ihn atomphysik
aufgeschlüsselt werden der letztlich die
quantenmechanik zugrunde liegt wir haben
uns umfassend an die idee gewöhnt dass
die physik alles erklären kann selbst
aspekte des geistes tatsächlich kann man
das gehirn als physikalische system
ansehen und mit den regeln der physik
erklären bestimmte dinge lassen sich
damit aber nicht erklären nämlich der
geist aber den wir vorher sprachen
und insbesondere das subjektive erleben
warum produzieren all diese
physikalischen prozesse einen
subjektiven erlebnisgehalt der sich wie
etwas gefällt die philosophen nennen das
ja quali also diese vorstellung dass
sich eben etwas auch anfühlt wie etwas
das eben nicht nur die der eindruck der
farbe rot auf meiner retina entstehen
ich fühle dieses rot ich erlebe roth nun
ist eine schwierigkeit ja beim dualismus
wenn ihr noch kurz dabei bleiben dass es
zwei substanzen gibt ist ja dass man
sich nicht so recht vorstellen kann wie
die eigentlich interagieren sollen und
dicker material sehr lustige idee
descartes hatte diese idee der
zirbeldrüse die im mittelhirn sitzt und
die vorstellung war dass da eigentlich
diese interaktion geschieht das ist ja
schon problem was touristen haben wie
sollen diese beiden unterschiedlichen
welten übereinander eben wie
funktionieren die karte legte einen
traditionell dualistischen ansatz in dem
körper und geist grundsätzlich
unterschiedlich sind aber miteinander
interagieren
das führt wie sie richtig sagen zum
problem der interaktion gemäss descartes
verliefe die interaktion über einen teil
des gehirns die zirbeldrüse signale
werden vom physischen gehirn zum nicht
physischen geist gesendet der dann ein
bisschen nachdenkt und seinerseits ein
signal zurück ans gehirn schickt das
darauf eine handlung startet ich sage
dann etwas laufe irgendwohin oder trinke
wasser weil ich durstig bin ich erlebte
durst
darauf ging ein signal an mein gehirn
und ich trank wasser aber wie geschieht
das und wie passt das mit uns um wissen
von der physik zusammen
die physik scheint zu sagen dass
physikalische systeme geschlossen sind
so dass der geist nicht auf sie
einwirken und die physik durcheinander
einen kann die interaktion ist das große
problem einer dualistischen sicht damit
verlegte sich das interesse auf einer
materielle sichtweise
der alles physikalisch ist genau man
könnte ja sagen wenn ihr keinen ort
finden wo diese interaktion passiert
dann ist das bewusstsein einfach eine
illusion dann gibt's das hat einfach
nicht das leben wäre sehr viel einfacher
ohne bewusstsein
dies verleitete einige zusagen das
bewusstsein wäre eine trügerische
illusion eine täuschung
verursacht durch unsere revolutionären
selbst modelle
wir glauben bewusstsein zu haben sind
aber tatsächlich alle zombies geistlose
kreaturen ohne jedes bewusstsein
das ist eine einfache und elegante
lösung und eine sehr nüchterne
betrachtung der realität
sie ist aber nicht glaubhaft wenn das
bewusstsein ist für die meisten von uns
eine feststehende tatsache nichts war
für descartes sicherer als seine
gedanken bewusst sein
eine visuelle erfahrung der schmerz den
ich jetzt in meiner hand fühle hat für
mich den status eines faktums und gehört
zu den dingen welche die wissenschafter
ein besseres verständnis unserer welt
untersuchen
für solche fakten brauchen wir
erklärungen und sie zu bestreiten
scheint mir unwissenschaftlich eine
person die das nicht glaubt eben
tatsächlich glaubt alles lässt sich
physikalisch erklären und ein physiker
list ist daniel dennett und daniel
dennett es vielleicht einer der
gegenspieler von ihnen sie haben sich
auch in zahlreichen gesprächen immer
wieder getroffen
er war auch zu gast bei uns um die
rasanten bewusstsein ist eine illusion
und wie kann sie vergleichen mit einer
art benutzeroberfläche eines handys
hören die um ganz kurzen das gehirn hat
ein problem
es besteht aus 86 milliarden euro
und diese sind zu allen möglichen fähig
es braucht also etwas das alles
vereinfacht
etwas das die aktivitäten großer
neuronen gruppen umformt damit sie
einfache dinge darstellen
dieses phänomen erinnert an eine
technische errungenschaft die ingenieure
erst kürzlich entwickelt haben nämlich
die benutzeroberfläche von computern
oder smartphones ihr handy ist ein
unglaublich kompliziertes gerät schicht
um schicht software hardware und für
mehr aus milliarde teilchen genauer
wollen sie das gar nicht wissen
sie wollen einzig eine auf metaphern
basieren der benutzeroberfläche einfach
irgendwie illusorisch man spricht daher
auch vom benutzer illusion
doch wer ist der benutzer das bin ich
und das handy vermittelt mir eine
illusion
aber es ist eine gutartige willkommene
illusion wenn sie vereinfacht ihr leben
lang ihr können sie ihr handy
kontrollieren und damit tun was sie
wollen
das ist die idee das gehirn verfügt über
eine eigene benutzer illusion
das heißt es es vereinfacht den input
der regulieren muss was ich als nächstes
tun und das resultat sind sie dass
bewusstes subjekt das aus dieser
interaktion zwischen den benutzer
flächen der beiden gehirnhälften
hervorgeht es gibt keine stelle im
gehirn wo alles zusammenkommt und das
bewusstsein sitzt ich bezeichne es als
katholisches theater für der guard war
es die zirbeldrüse im zentrum des
gehirns eine art fakt verbindung zur
seele durch die asien durch muss um
bewusst zu werden auf brillante weise
verrückt es gibt keinen solchen ort was
der intelligente weise geschätzte
homunculus anscheinend im kontrollraum
muss verteilt werden auf neuronale
instanzen die kein bewusstsein nahrung
aber diese arbeit leistet ist das
bewusstsein so etwas wie eine
benutzeroberfläche
gemäss dennett brauchen wir das
bewusstsein als werkzeug um über den
geist nachzudenken
damit bin ich soweit einverstanden das
bewusstsein ist ein grundlegender ansatz
um über uns selbst nachzudenken
dann aber fügt er hinzu dass es ein
historisches werkzeug sei um über den
geist nachzudenken
das bewusstsein scheine real sei aber
selbst eine illusion
[Musik]
gehen wir der sache auf den grund was
sind illusionen wenn ich einen start ins
wasser stelle und der dann gebogen
erscheint erlebe ich eine illusion
eine illusion aber ist nichts anderes
als eine bewusste erfahrung seine sieht
minister radikaler sein wenn dennett
sagte die welt sei eine illusion oder
wir sehen unser gehirn durch die linse
des bewusstseins und würden so über die
struktur des gehirns getäuscht
wenn sich dies noch nachvollziehen dann
wäre aber das bewusstsein real und es
würde uns täuschen bezüglich des
beobachteten tatsächlich sagt der nett
aber dass das bewusstsein selbst eine
illusion ist
wir haben eine unbewusste illusion und
das bewusstsein wird irgendwie haben
diese betrachtung ist in sie schön und
nüchtern scheint aber grundsätzlich
nicht vereinbar mit unseren daten
die frage ist ja auch was man eigentlich
meint mit dem begriff der illusion denn
es wäre ja wahrscheinlich nicht sagen
wir müssen einander korrigieren und die
ganze zeit sagen du bildest dir nur ein
dass du denkst du seist einig oder dass
du wirklich liebeskummer hat
das sind irgendwie nur deine hormonellen
veränderungen oder so das heißt die
lebenswelt ist ja vielleicht noch einmal
getrennt von den philosophischen
erklärungen dahinter und dennoch scheint
es einen unterschied zu machen ob ein
roboter sagen würde ein schaltkreis ist
kaputt oder ob jemand sagt ich bin
traurig ob ich sagen würde meinen
serotoninspiegel ist zu tief oder ob ich
sage ich fühle mich deprimiert und genau
für diese lebensweltlichen eindrücke
erlebnisse eben für diese quali haben
die physiker listen keine erklärung
gerade das subjektive erleben erlaubt
uns die sinnhaftigkeit im leben der
menschen zu erkennen und sie als
leidensfähige wesen mit moralischen
status zu betrachten
nehmen wir rücksichtsvoll begegnen
sollten warum ist es uns nicht egal wie
wir mit anderen menschen umgehen
es ist mir egal wie ich dieses glas
wasser behandle ich kann einen schluck
nehmen ohne ihm schaden zugefügt zu
haben weil wir dem wasser kein
bewusstsein zu schreiben
ein computerprogramm oder ein roboter
kann ich wie ein mechanismus behandeln
es ist die bewusste erfahrung die uns
wichtig macht was denkt sie denn die
würde daniel dennett oder andere
physikalischen moral erklären warum
sollten wir freundlich respekt
voreinander
er müsste wohl sagen dass etwas anderes
als das bewusstsein moralischen status
begründen
vielleicht sähe er alles als ein produkt
der evolution weil uns diese moralische
haltungen nützlich und entsprechende
gemeinschaften erfolgreicher war
vielleicht gibt es auch andere
erklärungsmöglichkeiten für einen
physiker listen wenn das bewusstsein
aber eine illusion ist kann sie
unsere moralischen status oder die
sinnhaftigkeit unseres lebens nicht
begründen
sie müssen also andere gründe finden das
erfordert aber ein sehr radikales
umdenken in der art und weise wie wir
bei uns nachdenken
sie haben am von paar minuten auch schon
den zombie erwähnt also warum ist es ein
unterschied zu denken niemand ist ein
zombie oder eben nicht ein zombie und
vielleicht können wir dieses problem
kurz erklären weil es auch eine große
rolle spielt in ihrer philosophie wir
könnten zum beispiel vorstellen
es gebe einen zombie von mir also eine
perfekte nachbildung hier wäre der
zombie und der zombie der sieht von
außen genau so aus wie ich der bewegte
sich gleich der spricht gleich aber wenn
man rein gucken würde während darin nur
schaltkreise da wären verschiedene
drehte und so weiter und wenn wir jetzt
einen unterschied machen und sagen den
zombie den dürfen wir schreddern den
können wir zerstören den können wir vom
strom nehmen
aber mich nicht dann setzen wir
eigentlich voraus dass es eben so etwas
sie bewusstsein gibt songs sind eine
hypothese ein von philosophen
postulierte gedankenexperiment um über
das bewusstsein zu reflektieren
niemand glaubt dass songs tatsächlich
existieren aber als hypothese sind sie
äußerst nützlich
ich spreche hier mit ihnen und ich bin
der festen überzeugung dass sie
bewusstsein haben in ihrer kommunikation
zeigen sie alle anzeichen für
bewusstsein denken erleben wie aber kann
ich sicher sein das bewusstsein haben
die idee dass sie ohne inneres leben
hier sitzen sprechen und addieren
könnten ist für mich denkbar
sie könnten ein roboter ein automat sei
ein objektiver prozess ohne subjektives
erleben
ich kann mir die idee dass ihr ein
sorbet sein könnten einleuchtend machen
ich glaube nicht dass hier einer sind
ich bin es ganz sicher nicht
ich versichere ihnen ich habe warum aber
sind wir kein
was ist der unterschied zwischen uns und
zombies warum hat die natur beseelte
wesen geschaffen und keine song dies vor
dem hintergrund der songs lassen sich
fragen des bewusstseins oder der moral
trefflich diskutieren wenn wir umgeben
wären von sambia ohne bewusstsein
könnten wir diese behandeln wie
ungezählte objekte oder bewusstlose tote
körper hätten sie dann moralischen
status
viele würden das wohl in abrede stellen
gesprochen und uns überlegt was könnte
eine gegen theorie sein und ich habe mir
überlegt warum ist es für sie eigentlich
so wichtig dass der physikalisch muss
falsch ist oder was hat sie auch dazu
gebracht den physikalisch muss zurück zu
weisen sie haben viel jetzt schon
darüber gesprochen dass sie glauben dass
diese theorie überhaupt nicht abbildet
wie wir in der welt stehen wie wir uns
sehen wie wir unsere gegenüber sie aber
eine ein interessantes detail in ihrem
leben ist auch dass sie selber
synästhesie ist waren bis zu ihren
jugendjahren dh die ohren wenn sie musik
gehört haben
zugleich farben gesehen und eigentlich
denke ich sie sind wahrscheinlich eine
person die sehr viele quali erlebt hat
sie hatten sehr sehr viele sind es
eindrücken ist das vielleicht auch etwas
was sie denken für gerade für sie die
sie so stark mit quali jahr immer
konfrontiert waren mit so vielen
eindrücken ist es so wichtig an diesem
bewusstsein festgehalten
möglicherweise hat das eine rolle
gespielt so als kind hatten bestimmte
lieder oder akkorde ihrer eigenen farbe
oft verschiedene schattierungen von grün
oder braun ab und zu aber gab es ein
reines herz
irgendwann um die 20 verschwand das es
ist offenbar üblich dass eine
synästhesie in der kindheit auftritt und
später verschwindet ich schrieb damals
in mein tagebuch
was ist los plötzlich haben die songs
keine farben mehr
ja das war traurig ob es eine rolle
spielte für ein nachdenken über das
bewusstsein
ich denke es lenkte mich auf diese dinge
die quali a wie sie sagten
die farben die klänge und die beziehung
zwischen ihnen etwas anderes kam noch
dazu ich wurde kurzsichtig auf einer ich
brauchte also eine brille heute trage
ich kontakt mit der brille wurde die
welt plötzlich dreidimensional
ich dachte eigentlich schon vorher dass
die welt dreidimensional war aber als
ich mit beiden augen sah wurde die welt
plötzlich zum 3d film isch kandidiere
objektiven prozesse im gehirn wo beide
augen zusammen spielen um informationen
über raumtiefe zu produzieren
warum aber hatte ich diese subjektive
erfahrung dass die welt plötzlich raus
springt und in 3d erscheinen
das war eine frage nach dem subjektiven
erleben und letztendlich dem bewusstsein
warum erlebte ich diese objektiven
prozesse wo über die beiden augen
informationen zusammengeführt werden
subjektiv als raumtiefe dabei ist zehn
jahre alt und sie haben ja selber auch
sehr lange musik gemacht sie haben eine
eine rockband weiß ich ob sie die noch
haben die hieß sondern wie blues band
hatte das schon was zu tun mit dem
zombie gedankenexperiment oder haben sie
das zombie gedankenexperiment liegen der
bands ich bin ich habe zwar rockstar
fantasien aber kein musikalisches talent
ich treffe beim singen auch die töne
nicht aber ab und an versuche ich den
zombie blues
er gründet auf diesen gedanken
experiment mit den sommer
die idee ist wie es wäre ein zombie zu
sein und kein bewusstsein zu haben man
würde so viel verpassen
deshalb bleibt einem nichts anderes als
den saum die blues zu singen
das ist wunderschön das ist ihr text und
einen verse gibt sich dann aus dem
nächsten zum beispiel an einer
consciousness konferenz wo jemand seine
theorie vorstellt und genau weiß was das
bewusstsein ist da singen
[Musik]
das leben wäre ganz schön traurig wenn
wir nicht bewusst werden jetzt möchte
ich mit ihnen über ihre theorie sprechen
vorher vielleicht noch ganz kurz würde
mich noch interessieren was eigentlich
ihre auffassung von philosophie ist mir
fällt auf dass ich wenige philosophie
professorin kennen sie so hoch
dekorierte sich zugleich so sehr
einsetzen auch für ein breites
philosophie verständnis und vielleicht
nur ein paar beispiele zu nennen
sie sitzen in der jury des berggruen
preises für philosophie ein preis der
einmal jährlich vergeben wird eine
million us-dollar für ideen die die welt
verändern
sie sind auch der gründer von vier
papers tork einer online plattform auf
der ganz viele papers in philosophie zu
finden sind auch bücher
das heißt sie versuchen philosophie
zugänglich zu machen für alle und auf
ihrer website sammeln sie philosophische
witze und satire philosophische cartoons
das heißt philosophie scheint für sie
etwas ganz breites zu sein
was würden sie sagen was ist eigentlich
der zweck der philosophie in der
heutigen zeit
der zweck oder das ziel der philosophie
nun ich denke bei der philosophie geht
es um die grundlage von
du blickst überall hin und fragt warum
die kann das sein was erklärt dass
philosophie führt über wissenschaftliche
erklärungen hinaus bei der philosophie
geht es darum jeden stein umzudrehen um
zu verstehen
für mich ist philosophie ein proaktives
streben nach verstehen
der wille sich selbst zu verstehen ich
versuchte mein eigenes bewusstsein zu
verstehen wenn man sich darüber lange
genug gedanken macht landet man weiter
philosophie genauso wenn man versucht
ein politisches thema zu vertiefen oder
ein aktuelles thema wie nationalismus in
der politik woher kommt das worauf
gründet er welche für die so fischen
wurzeln haben bestimmte formen der
demokratie sagt man oft genug warum
betreibt man philosophie ich glaube fast
alle philosophie anwender über das
nachdenken was ihm wichtig ist
vielleicht nicht auf akademischer stufe
als ich mir fragen zu meiner sehkraft
stellte philosophierte ich ja bevor ich
überhaupt wusste was viele suchen ist
ich identifiziere mich mit menschen
welche die philosophie für sich
entdecken und sich ihr nähern
dafür möchte ich ihnen das rüstzeug
geben und glauben sie gibt es in der
philosophie wirklich fortschritte im
fortschritt verläuft langsam in der
philosophie es gibt fortschritte dinge
verändern sich wir entwickeln ein
besseres verständnis
aber es gibt wenig über das man sich in
der philosophie einig ist in den
naturwissenschaften gelangt man über
experimentelle methoden zu einer
einigung in wichtigen fragen
dass das in der philosophie nicht
wirklich geschieht lässt sich erklären
viele der großen wissenschafts fragen
waren ursprünglich fragen der
philosophie
irgendwann findet ein problem eine
lösung auf die sich alle verständigen
ab diesem zeitpunkt nennen wir es nicht
mehr philosophie sondern
naturwissenschaft nannte sich selbst ein
er war naturphilosoph der sich gedanken
zu raum und zeit
er entwickelte dafür exakte methoden vor
und plötzlich nannte mannes physik die
physik war also ein spin off der
philosophie und nicht das einzige die
philosophie produzierte auch die
psychologie linguist und die
wirtschaftswissenschaften
wann immer jemand ein philosophisches
problem löst ist es nicht mehr
philosophie die philosophie ist also
dieser korb in den allzu hartnäckigen
problemen für die noch keiner eine
lösung gefunden hat das heißt eigentlich
dass daniel dennett gar nicht mehr
philosoph wäre weil er ja sozusagen sagt
es ist alles nur physikalisch das heißt
das bewusstsein problem haben wir gelöst
das sind einfach irgendwelche neuronen
gewimmel gewitter in unserem kopf und
damit fertig ende der durchsage keine
philosophie
nun ich glaube janet philosophiert er
rege ich kenne den seit 30 jahren
und wie ehedem und wickelt er seine
geschichte weiter um die menschen davon
zu überzeugen sein philosophischer
standpunkt unterscheidet sich von meinen
und natürlich denke ich dass er falsch
liegt aber er hat mit dem philosophieren
nicht aufgehört
er hat einfach einen besonders radikalen
ansatz
ich wünsche ihnen dafür nur das beste
umso besser wenn er die leute von seinem
ansatz überzeugen kann
tatsächlich aber scheint seiner ansicht
das bewusstsein eine illusion ist wenig
anklang zu finden
die leute finden dies widerspricht ihrer
erfahrung der welt grundlegend und
erklärt das phänomen in keiner weise
damit sage ich aber nicht dass dies
nicht philosophie sei es ist philosophie
respektable philosophie sogar bloß
einfach falsch ich dachte nur wenn man
quasi sagt alles was empirisch erklärbar
ist wird irgendwann nicht mehr zu
philosophie gehören dann könnte man ja
auch sagen das problem des bewusstseins
ist irgendwann kein philosophisches
problem mehr
wenn wir alles nur mit algorithmen im
kopf erklären könnten also wenn wir eine
gänzlich materialistische vorstellung
des bewusstseins hetzen und das beweisen
könnten dann der es streng genommen kein
philosophisches problem mehr
wenn ich ire
ja die philosophie wandelt sich im laufe
der zeit zur naturwissenschaft die
philosophie von raum und zeit wurde zur
wissenschaft von raum und zeit
ich würde es begrüßen wenn die
philosophie des bewusstseins zu
wissenschaftlers bewusstseins würde und
alle probleme gelöst werden
noch wissen wir nicht wie eine solche
wissenschaft aussehen könnte
wir können nicht einfach voraussetzen
dass es eine neurowissenschaft eines
bewusstseins oder eine
computerwissenschafter algorithmen
werden
ich sehe nicht wie alleine dadurch
bewusst sein erklärt werden könnte aber
vielleicht wird es eine neue
wissenschaft wir sollten das bewusstsein
als fundamentale eigenschaft der
realität ansehen sowie raum zeit und
massen der physik als fundamentale
eigenschaften gelten wenn es uns gelänge
eine theorie zu entwickeln und das
bewusstsein aber bestimmte gesetze
adäquat mit dem rest der wissenschaft
verbindet hätten wir vielleicht eine
wissenschaftliche theorie des
bewusstseins die bestimmte
philosophische probleme auslösen würde
aber an diesem punkt sind wir noch nicht
und weil wir noch nicht an diesem punkt
sind gibt es unglaublich viel forschung
zu diesem thema hier nur zwei ihrer
dicken sie waren diese tage an einer
großen konferenzen interlaken zum thema
consciousness zum thema bewusstsein da
hat sich sozusagen die creme de la creme
der bewusstseinsforschung getroffen ein
sehr interdisziplinäres feld an
forscherinnen und forschern
sie haben da auch den main theaterpreis
verlieren erhalten ganz herzliche
gratulation dazu arbeiten und ich würde
gerne mit ihm jetzt eben einen schritt
weiter gehen zur lösung dieses problems
und sie haben ja für mich überraschend
ein neues papier geschrieben
das ist noch nicht erschienen das wird
erst erscheinen diese nannte mind body
problem und da sagen sie sozusagen auch
es gibt so eine eine ein zitat oder eine
lebensweisheit und philosophen
da sagt man man beginnt meistens als
material ist dann wird man dual ist dass
man denkt es gibt eben zwei dinge
liebeskummer und bücher
danach wird man sich ist da werden wir
noch darüber sprechen denkt also alles
irgendwie belebt und danach wird man
ideal ist und sie prüfen in diesem
papier ob der idealismus richtig sein
könnte der idealismus ist sozusagen die
gegen theorie zu denn alles ist idee
alles ist geist
das müssen sie erklären
idealismus ist eine der großen
traditionellen metaphysischen der
realität im physik realismus ist alles
materie im dualismus gibt es materie und
geist idealismus wiederum hat alles
seinen ursprung im geist der klassische
idealist war barclay mit seinem diktum
sein ist wahrnehmen demnach existiert
dieses buch nur in der wahrnehmung und
dem erfahrenen des buches und nicht
außerhalb des geistes diese form des
idealismus fand ich nie wirklich
reizvoll für die erklärung unseres
erlebens brauchen wir eine welt
außerhalb unserer erfahrung ein anderer
weg zum idealismus führt über den plan
psychisch muss über den ich mir in
jüngster zeit gedanken gemacht habe und
denen sie vorher angesprochen haben
er besagt dass es elemente von
bewusstsein in der gesamten materiellen
welt geben könnte wenn wir sagen dass
das bewusstsein nicht auf einfachere
prozesse reduzierbar ist haben wir das
problem der interaktion als dual ist
steht man vor dem schwierigen problem
herauszufinden wie das bewusstsein mit
der physikalischen welt interagiert die
alternative besteht darin zu sagen das
tief im urgrund der physikalischen welt
anteile von bewusstsein vorhanden sind
bis hin zu den elementarteilchen den
elektronen und photonen wenn die gesamte
physikalische welt von bewusstsein
durchdrungen ist fällt die notwendigkeit
der interaktion mit etwas davon
getrennten weg sie umfasst ja
bewusstsein von anbeginn wenn man aber
so weit gegangen ist zu sagen dass es
überall in der physikalischen welt
anteile von bewusstsein gibt ist es nur
noch ein kleiner schritt zur aussage die
ganze physikalische welt besteht aus
bewusstsein die beschaffenheit eines
elektrons oder eines neutrons ist nichts
anderes als bewusstsein und woge warum
genau landen sie dann nicht bei der
ersten form des idealismus der sagen
würde dieses buch existiert nur weil sie
in ihren kopf existiert wasser bei
diesen park idealismus
es gibt ein altbekanntes problem bei
dieser form des idealismus
ich sehe das buch mache die erfahrung
schau wegschaue wieder hin dass du bist
immer noch da bei barclay war es der
baum im hof der bei der rückkehr in den
hof immer noch da ist
um das zu erklären hat barclay gott ins
spiel gebracht er sagte es ist alles in
gottes geist gott schaut immer auf den
baum oder das motto gottes geist dient
als objektive realität
ich bin kein christ ich glaube nicht an
gott
ich sehe keine rolle für einen
kosmischen geist da halte ich es eher
mit den punks hissten die die physik als
anhalterin los buches sehen und nicht
gott die waage mit dem zusätzlichen
effekt dass die physik selbst anteile
von bewusstsein hat vielleicht sind all
die elektronen und photonen selbst
kleine orte von bewusstsein schauen was
das ist nicht ganz einfach zu verstehen
wir machen wir ein paar beispiele also
hier drehen dürfe es auch bewusst sein
nach einem sich der psychiater gibt es
überall ein bisschen bewusstsein
vielleicht das ist glaube ich ziemlich
schwer zu verstehen vielleicht beginnen
wir immer noch mit dem pflanzen
viele menschen glauben ja wenn sie durch
den wald gehen der wald ist beseelt ich
glaube das ist eine institution die ganz
viele menschen haben das hier ist ein
bus sei aber es nicht irgendein bonns an
das ist georg georg gehört meiner
kollegin gina messerli und sie hat eine
einen artikel geschrieben über ihr
verhältnis zu georg ehrmann online
nachlesen was haben sie denn davon also
glauben sie zb tatsächlich bäume
pflanzen dieser bonsai sind besiegt
nun ich weiß es nicht ich weiß nicht
welches die richtige betrachtungsweise
des bewusstseins ist faschismus oder
idealismus beides in spekulationen über
die es sich aber lohnt nachzudenken wenn
der pazifismus zutrifft ist es möglich
dass george subjektives erleben kennt er
kann ja bestimmte informationen
verarbeiten wenn eine pflanze einer
lichtquelle ausgesetzt ist sieht man
dass die pflanze in diese richtung
wächst zeitraffer sieht es dann so aus
als ob sich jemand danach streckt
mich reizt der gedanke dass eine
verarbeitung von informationen immer auf
das vorhandensein von bewusstseins
elementen hinweis ein organismus wie
george verarbeitet tatsächlich bestimmte
informationen und hat deshalb vielleicht
ein wenig bewusstsein
aber dann hätte nicht nur george sondern
jedes einzelne blatt
jedes teilchen einen bestimmten grad von
bewusstsein das ist eine radikale
sichtweise und vielleicht schwierig zu
glauben aber vielleicht ist es ja auch
nur kultur bedingt schwierig menschen
anderer kulturen haben überhaupt kein
problem damit pflanzen oder andere
lebensformen als bisher zu sehen
es gibt ja einen trend bei der
zuschreibung von
vor jahren erkannte man nur menschen
oder höchstens noch primaten oder
vielleicht affen bewusstsein zu heute
ist man bereit zu sagen das säugetier
und wahrscheinlich auch fische bewusst
sind
über ameisen streitet man sich und wohl
bald schon über würmer der kreis der
bewussten lebewesen erweitert sich das
ist der trend in wissenschaft und
philosophie und vielleicht ändert man ja
irgendwann mal bei george ganz am anfang
als über das bewusstsein gesprochen
haben hat mir diese idee der quali ja
wir hatten diese idee es ist eben nicht
nur so dass mein serotoninspiegel tief
ist sondern was ich mich traurig fühle
das sind zb bewusste erfahrungen die wir
haben
würden sie sagen ein baum oder eine
ameise haben eine andere form von
bewusstsein oder ist es eine frage von
geraden also geht es um quantität
quantität mehr oder weniger bewusst sein
oder ganz andere formen von bewusstsein
ich nehme an es geht um andere formen
von bewusstsein auch unser bewusstsein
kennt viele verschiedene ausprägungen
es gibt visuelles bewusstsein mit seinen
farben und formen auditives bewusstsein
mit tonhöhe und farbe körperbewusstsein
das sind alles ganz unterschiedliche
formen von bewusstsein
dann sind auch gedanken und gefühle
wiederum etwas ganz anderes wenn
pflanzen bewusst sind würde ich annehmen
dass ihre formen des bewusstseins sich
noch stärker bieten
mein kollege thomas nagel stellte die
frage wie es sich anfühlt eine
fledermaus zu sein
fledermäuse nutzen ein solarsystem zur
wahrnehmung bei dem der abprallende
schal ihnen ein bild der welt vermittelt
weil dieses wahrnehmung system sich
grundsätzlich von unserem unterscheidet
ist es uns wohl unmöglich zu wissen wie
es ist eine fledermaus zu sein
vielleicht hätte er fragen sollen wie es
sich anfühlt eine pflanze zu sein
ich nehme an dass die wahrnehmung von
pflanzen so grundlegend anders sind dass
wir keine direkten erkenntnisse darüber
gewinnen kann
aber ich kann ihnen trotzdem in der
frage noch folgen ich kann noch
verstehen
was sie meinen wenn sie sagen wie fühlte
sich wohl an george zu sein aber ich
kann ihnen nicht mehr folgen zu fragen
wie fühlt es sich an dieser stift zu
sein
glauben sie dass für interessant ihr
bewusstseins kreis hat sich so weit
ausgedehnt dass pflanzen darin
eingeschlossen sind nicht aber stifter
warten als noch ein paar jahre
schauen wir mal klicke hier ich kann
also zeichen auf papier setzen oder ich
kann den stift in die eine oder andere
richtung bugsieren
wir sehen stifter gemeinhin nicht als
informations verarbeiten der geräte aber
in ihnen stecken teilchen die auch
informationen ansprechen
er bewegt sich in die eine oder der
andere richtungen und dieser gene
zustand entspricht vielleicht einen
bestimmten erfahrungs element natürlich
ist das ein etwas radikaler schritt
einige paare psychischer sagen denn auch
nicht dass jedes system bewusst ist aber
dass die grundlegenden systeme die
teilchen dass elektronen das photon
bewusst sind und dass bestimmte
kombinationen davon bewusstsein haben
dies nennt man das kombinations problem
wie schaffen kombinationen von bewussten
teilchen ein bewusstes etwas und welche
kombinationen wenn ihnen die idee des
bewussten stiftes nicht gefällt bleiben
wir mal bei der ansicht dass nur
bestimmte arten und konfigurationen von
kombinationen bewusstsein schaffen so
können wir vielleicht george in den
kreis eintreten lassen aber nicht in
stift meine kollegin katrin henniger des
wissenschaftsmagazins einstein war bei
einem pflanzenforscher und hat ihn
gefragt warum wir eigentlich die idee so
schön finden dass pflanzen vielleicht
beseelt sind oder irgendetwas empfinden
hören wir im pflanzenforscher noch ganz
gut ich glaube mir wünsche
wir führen diese mannschaft zusammen im
universum mit dieser fähigkeit
reflektieren berühmt nach aussagen
machen
darum suchen jahren anderem andere
organismen irgendwie es gegenüber und
versuchen leute 20 minuten takt 1920
montag fast den machen kann oder dass
die 20 jährigen bewusst sie hätten
dadurch viele politiker hat das ganze
dass wir nach dem deutlichen intelligenz
zuschlägt oder emotionale komponente
gibt keinerlei reaktion der pflanze
sonst natürlich auch 20 verschiedene
möglichkeiten um die wachsende erwartung
für sie körperzellen media ag ihre
entlang haben nur 27
sie war auf jeder messe abstauber wenn
sie nachher besser von den volks dem
taser betriebe sie reagiere eventuell
sogar auf gut sagen mal wenn wir mit
fragen zur berliner josef die berliner
liegen rekurs art und weise also es geht
dann sind das verhalten von 20 und das
verhalten von andritz zogen bei milden
singapur sagen wir halten aber die haben
uns nicht um den bewuchs die pc im
wohnzimmer genießen will bauer selber
wusste bzw 20 auf aber um ein kritisches
ist es verständlich dass sehr sehr
spannendes wachse sehr spannender
organismus war um als signal integriert
aber verschiedene hatten ist auch dass
sie will aber genau das zentrale
nervensystem haben ein stück weit sagt
der pflanzenforscher ja auch wir denken
die welt ist beseelt weil wir uns ein
bisschen alleine fühlen
das wäre keine befriedigende erklärung
für sie nun ich sehe darin keine
psychologische erklärung dafür warum wir
pflanzen bewusstsein zu schreiben
wollten nach meinem dafürhalten sehen
die meisten menschen pflanzen nicht als
beseelt es widerspricht der intuition
einzelne können sich vielleicht für die
idee erwärmen um uns von unserer
einsamkeit in der welt abzulenken gibt
es andere menschen
dann können wir darüber sprechen wer
sonst noch bewusstsein hat es wäre in
gewisser weise ja auch sein
in pflanzen gewählt werden so dachte ich
mal ich sollte nichts beseeltes essen
wenn tiere ein bewusstsein haben
entsteht daraus ein bestimmter druck
keine tiere zu essen aber wenigstens
gibt's dann ja noch pflanzen
wenn wir dann entscheiden dass die auch
beseelt sind wird es langsam eng
was kann man da noch essen vielleicht
künstliche chemische nahrungsmitteln die
nicht von lebenden organismen stammen
wir werden dann wohl sie hungrig sein
naja es gibt die so genannten ins
rotarier die nur essen was die pflanze
freiwillig abgibt also nur früchte die
zu boden fallen die darf man dann essen
es gibt ja dann könnte man auch
überfahrene und verendete tiere essen
beides sei ich bin teilweise aus diesem
grund kein vegetarier moralisch geht es
um die art und den grad von bewusstsein
denke das ist nur wie sonst vielleicht
plötzlich werden die leute wieder
abschied nehmen von vegetarismus wie sie
sagen weil sie denken die pflanze hat
genauso bewusst sein
ich würde gerne mit denen doch einen
schritt weiter gehen und noch über die
digitalisierung sprechen die
digitalisierung ist ja das große thema
unserer zeit und eine frage ist auch ob
eigentlich künstliche künstliche
intelligenz irgendwann bewusstsein haben
wird und sie sagen an einer stelle das
fand ich sehr interessant wir sollten
uns nicht davor fürchten dass künstliche
intelligenz der einst bewusst sein
könnte sondern umgekehrt fürchten dass
künstliche intelligenz geschaffen wird
die nicht bewusst seien
haben sie jetzt weil sie dann zum
beispiel vielleicht eher unmoralisch
sein wird es wird eines tages wohl sehr
viele künstliche intelligenzen in der
welt gehen und vielleicht müssen wir
irgendwann einmal unsere gehirne auf
eine software hochladen
weil ihre fähigkeiten die unseren weit
übersteigen und sie uns mit ihrer
geschwindigkeit weit hinter sich
gelassen
so wie wir auch künstliche gliedmaßen
und der herzen bekommen müssen wir dann
vielleicht unsere denkprozesse auf
künstlern giguere hochladen und werden
damit selbst zu künstlich intelligenten
wesen
wenn man sich die welt von morgen als
eine welt vorstellt die von künstlicher
intelligenz beherrscht wird spielt es
eine große rolle und diese künstlich
intelligenten systeme ein bewusstsein
haben sehen uns diese ki system alle
song dies wird unsere welt kein
bewusstsein erkennen es wäre eine welt
ohne sinn ohne moralischen werte ein
massenmord an allen bewussten leben eine
enorme moralische katastrophe haben aber
die künstliche intelligenten wesen wir
schaffen oder sein werden bewusst sein
wird sinnhaftes und moralisches leben
weiter bestehen deshalb ist die frage ob
carney bewusstsein hat alle entscheidend
hat kein bewusstsein ist die menschheit
möglicherweise dem untergang geweiht und
alles bewusstsein wäre ausgelöscht
umgekehrt ist eine bewusste ki
vielleicht schlicht und einfach die
zukünftige entwicklung unseres
bewusstseins und sie glauben dass wenn
bewusstsein erst einmal da ist dann ist
es eine frage auch der evolution das
sich eben auch moral herausbildet wie es
zb auch sehen bei primaten die auch
autistisches verhalten zum beispiel
zeigen also würden auch roboter die
bewusstsein haben irgendwelche frauen
von moral ausbilden denken sie nun wir
wissen das bewusstsein keine garantie
ist für moral
es gibt sehr viele psychopathen die
bewusstsein haben
viel wird davon abhängen wie wir unsere
systeme gestalten selbstverständlich
könnten wir auch unmoralisches system
entwickeln wenn wir das wollen
deshalb sollten je geschaffen die neben
der intelligenz und rationalität auch
moral hat
kann zwar der ansicht dass moral ein
aspekt der vernunft ist
daraus folgt das perfekte rationale ki
system auch perfekt moralisch sind
hoffen wir dass er recht hatte so können
wir mehr und mehr rationale ki systeme
schaffen die dann auch immer moralischer
werte und unter allgemein verbindlichen
maximen gemäss kants kategorischen
imperativ handeln
ich fürchte aber es wird raum für k s
beide ausprägungen geben wir müssen den
grundwerten wie wen unsere ki systeme
einbauen große sorge tragen
denn wenn die ks mächtig genug sind
werden ihre grundwerte wahrscheinlich
die weiterentwicklung der gesellschaft
bestimmen
noch einmal zurück mit ihnen zum zombie
problem weil was ich jetzt noch nicht
mal stehe wenn ich ihnen folgen ihrer
idee dass vielleicht der punk sich muss
die richtige lösung darstellt oder eben
sogar der idealismus und auch dieser
stift hier in einer bestimmten art und
weise bewusst ist dann frage ich sie
noch einmal wie können sie denn der
meinung sein dass es den zombie auf
gedankenexperiment geben könnte denn
dann müsste doch auch ein zombie immer
bewusst sein weil alles bewusst ist
die songs sind akkus eine hypothese es
gibt keine songs in der realen welt weil
es bewusst hält das gilt aber bloß für
unsere in anderen welten gibt es
vielleicht nur physikalisch ist kein
bewusstsein
das wäre das sambi universum dies ist
nicht unsere welt
hier gibt es keine zombies aber
philosophen lieben es über hypothetische
welten zu sprechen in unserer welt
gelten grundlegend der naturgesetze die
das bewusstsein lenken und mit
physikalischen prozessen verbinden
vielleicht gilt auch ein grundgesetz
wonach informationsflüsse auf
bewusstsein hinter
aber eine alternative welt ohne
bewusstsein wäre denkbar
ja wir können uns eine welt mit zombies
und ohne bewusstsein denken in einer
solchen welt hätte denn denn mit recht
hier gäbe es nur das physikalische und
kein bewusstsein
ich glaube nicht dass es unsere welt ist
aber es ist eine welt das finde ich
schwer nachvollziehbar weil wenn man den
idealismus folgt dann ist doch
eigentlich alles geist wie kann es denn
etwas leben ohne geist wenn sie wie
barclay einer sehr starken form des
idealismus anhängen und glauben dass
notwendigerweise alles geist ist kann es
keine songbeat oder rick welche wiesen
ohne geist geben weil dann alles geist
ist eine solch starke form von
idealismus akzeptiere ich nicht ich kann
mir welten ohne geist vorstellen geist
ist eine grundeigenschaft der realität
aber es kann auch andere geben oder zeit
vielleicht ich neige dazu zu glauben
dass es raum und zeit ohne bewusstsein
geben kann und wenn das stimmt ist die
starke form des idealismus falsch und
sambia sind dann mindestens vorstellbar
aber sie haben recht diese dinge sind
stark miteinander verwoben
je mehr man über psychisch muss und
idealismus nachdenkt desto stärker
kommen die zombie hypothese unter druck
und es heute eher saison und ich finde
es besonders interessant ihnen zuzuhören
weil ich immer noch im kopf haben dass
sie ursprünglich mathematiker sind dass
sie diese freude haben am logischen
denken und an den zahlen und der
eigentlich auch ihre schönen vorstellung
dass sich alles berechnen lässt
und jetzt landen sie beim idealismus
bringen sie selber diese welten noch
zusammen
tief in meinem innern bin ich ein
rationalist ich glaube man kann das
universum sorgfältiger logik
der blick in die geschichte zeigt dass
mathematisches und philosophisches
denken zusammengehören newton zb war ein
großartiger mathematiker und philosoph
so auch leibnitz ich bin heute tag ein
hoffnungsloser mathematiker aber ich
bediene mich immer noch gerne
mathematische logik wenn ich versuche zu
sehen wie ideen zusammen passen mir
gefallen elegante einfache strukturen
wie der physikalisch muss er mich aber
inhaltlich nicht überzeugt
in meiner suche nach einem ähnlich
attraktiven ansatz fühle ich mich zum
purismus und sogar zum idealismus
hingezogen weil auch hier das komplexe
auf einfache art erklärt wird es gibt
ein interessantes thema bezüglich der
frage auch wie wir unser bewusstsein
eigentlich erweitern könnten sie haben
erwähnt dass einige ideen natürlich ist
dass wir uns irgendwann irgendwelche
chips einbauen und unsere menschen in
allen kapazitäten auf diese art und
weise verbessern so genanntes new or
enhanced betreiben eine andere idee ist
substanzen zu uns nehmen psychedelische
drogen beispielsweise das ist gerade
unter philosophen im moment ein sehr
großes thema geworden
haben sie so was mal ausprobiert
interessiert sie dass das bewusstsein zu
erweitern mit substanzen
nun es gibt viele verschiedene arten
sein bewusstsein zu erweitern
ich habe ein bisschen mit
bewusstseinserweiternden substanzen
experimentiert einer der lektoren meines
ersten buches in der conscious meint vor
20 jahren sagte das ist toll aber es
braucht mehr daten philosophen sollten
also ständig mit psychedelischen drogen
experten
die datenlage sei weiter die menschliche
wahrnehmung ist beschränkt warum sie
nicht ausweiten
so habe ich das eine oder andere
probiert andere philosophen sind da
weiter gegangen
ich kenne einige die heute bücher über
psychedelische drogen schreiben aber man
kann sein bewusstsein auch über bildung
kultur und technologie erweitern unsere
interaktionen mit unseren smartphones
und mit computern erweitern unseren
geist und unser bewusstsein auch auf
eine gewisse weise wenn sie vorhin
gesagt haben es wäre ein
paralleluniversum möglich ohne
bewusstsein denken sie wäre auch eines
möglich wo ich sehr viel mehr
bewusstsein gibt
das ist eine sehr interessante frage
vielleicht haben wir erst eine bestimmte
phase in der entwicklung von bewusstsein
erreicht
ich will keine rangordnung von
bewusstsein aufstellen und behaupten wir
menschen werden weiter oben als die
privaten die ihrerseits höher sind als
hunde wollen neuson kommen aber es hat
sich etwas entwickelt formen von
bewusstsein haben sich erweitert mit uns
entstand ein bestimmter reichtum ein
bewusstsein
wir befinden uns irgendwo auf einem
entwicklungspfad über künftige ki oder
technologische implantate wird sich
unser geist wohl weiter entwickeln und
vielleicht stehen wir erst am anfang der
kosmischen entwicklung unseres geistes
wie nägel fragte wie es sich anfühlt
eine fledermaus zu sein könnten wir auf
fragen wie es sich anfühlt eine super
intelligent key zu sein
das können wir im moment nicht fassen
aber vielleicht blickt man in 10.000
jahren amüsiert zurück auf unsere
bewusstseins form gedacht
sie könnte mit ihrem begrenzten wissen
vom geist über zukünftige formen des
bewusstseins mutmaßen
aber man muss er irgendwo anfangen
wir haben aber ich hoffe dass da sammle
ich weiß letztendlich abschließend nur
wie es sich anfühlt ich zu sein und ich
bin sehr glücklich dass ich mit ihnen
sprechen contact vielen herzlichen dank
für dieses gespräch
jonas danke dass ihr hergekommen sind ja
wenn sie mehr wissen wollen über die
seele von george und erholungsräume
beruhigen dann schauen sie rein in die
sternstunde religion
meine kollegin olivia berlin war mit
einem mondholz forscher im wald
unterwegs jetzt gleich erzählt der film
der klang der freiheit von der
politischen sprengkraft des partisanen
leeds bella ciao und vieler poppitz die
sie bestimmt wieder erkennen wir von der
sternstunde philosophie verabschieden
und sind die sommerpause aber nicht vom
bildschirm an den kommenden sonntagen
sehen sie unsere lieblings gespräche der
letzten monate noch einmal wir sind
zurück ende august bis dahin einen guten
sommer
[Musik]
hi